die aufnahme ist willkommen meine damen
und herren fällt ihr artikel 13 nicht
kennen solltet dann wird es andere euch
das ganze jetzt mal der kernbank kann
mich am arsch lecken war am tag zuvor
richtig verkaufen deswegen ist in diesem
video noch immer halt so und wer bereits
in einem anderen video hier auf meinem
kanal den artikel 13 für euch erläutert
falls sie das video noch nicht gesehen
habt habe ich euch hier oben verlinkten
der beschreibung das könnt ihr euch
gerne anschauen da erkläre ich euch was
es mit artikeln 13 und vor allem auch
artikel 11 auf sich hat ich habe euch
auch noch andere newsartikel
nachrichtenbeiträge dazu in der
beschreibung verlinkt weil ich glaube
ich muss jetzt nicht noch mal alles
erklären und sagen warum artikel 13
scheiße sollte soll es vielmehr darum
gehen dass jetzt um 13 uhr 30 gleich in
20 minuten eine demonstration in köln
stattfindet juli findet eine
demonstration hier in köln statt
weil der gegen artikel 13 demonstriert
jetzt denn ich weiß nicht ob er die
aktuellen entwicklungen ist bekomme aber
artikel 13 ist so gut wie durch für
junge leute haben die petition
unterschrieben aber hey konflikt das
volk findet eine demonstration gegen
artikel 13 hier in köln stars kann es
jetzt gelaufen vom neumarkt zum
roncalliplatz und wir gehen ja jetzt
alle zusammen hin und schon ist das
ich weiß nicht ob die demo sehr groß
wird oder ob dann nur ein paar leute
sind die ist halt noch nicht so lange
festgelegt ist aber irgendwie was hast
du für eine charta ich habe zuerst mal
von der demo tatsächlich heute erfahren
heute morgen weil ich nicht so häufig in
twitter bin und habe das auch direkt
weiter verbreitet beim einer community
bei instyle haben das sollte die demo
stattfindet deswegen ich bin gespannt
bevor wir an dem statt treffpunkt der
demonstration angekommen sind wollte
sandra noch unbedingt mal meine kamera
haben und selber erich etwas mitteilen
und ich mache die 40 ich war zwar noch
nie auf der dämonen alter war so hart
wie gene zu ergebung es ist so ein
harter weg alter und so halter sind am
neumarkt angekommen und da hinten steht
schon ganz viele menschen wegen der demo
ist anscheinend doch ein bisschen größer
also sieht das ganze nicht gerade aus
ich habe schon meinen arm hoch als wir
sind echt einige leute nicht gedacht
dass nicht so viele leute kommen bei
zeit eine relativ spontane demo
alessandra geht jetzt um und fragt leute
warum sie gegen 13
möchte jetzt weiter befragen
ich frag mich dann doch mal selber ich
bin gegen artikel 13 des landes zu gegen
artikel 13 weil ich für mein artikel 13
konnte ich endlich mal richtig am arsch
lecken
wir schreien in 321 einfach gegen
artikel 3 2
es geht jetzt los meine damen und herren
die leute fangen an sich zu bewegen hier
vorne stehen menschen dicht dass diese
ankommen es ist schon ordentlich was los
dafür dass die demo wirklich vor drei
tagen angekündigt wurde das war nicht
aktueller zwischenstand
da ist die polizei hallo da hinten sind
wir gerade losgelaufen am neumarkt und
jetzt geht der ganze druck hier rüber
zum roncalliplatz keine ahnung oder
ist's her laufen alle friedlich rum auf
jeden fall
wir bräuchten aber noch ein bisschen
stimmung sondern ich war so schnell fad
das sind übliche war gefragt habe ob ich
ein e bike cup alter aber ich habe so
stolz
wir sind jetzt in der nähe vom dom
angekommen da hinten ist der dom
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt am dom angekommen und
schauen wie es jetzt weitergeht
also da ist der dom wir sind jetzt
gerade angekommen es gibt wirklich
komplett weiter ganz hinten auch endlich
mal ran zum alter mann sieht wirklich
nicht das ende das ist richtig stark
dafür dass die demo von zwei tagen jetzt
angekündigt wurde
heute ist eine wahnsinns kulisse hier
sind überall leute die um stein alle
anderen gucken da vorne
hallo
wie würde das mal bitte da ganz hinten
ich weiß nicht ob man das sie weil diese
kamera echt beschissen ist
gegen prominente weitergelaufen ganz
hinten runter bis hier den erzweg land
erfasst
[Musik]
ich bin grad live auf instagram hier wir
haben unser ziel erreicht sind direkt
vom so angekommen dass sandra
hier fordern sind die leiter der
demonstration und hier stehen jetzt
gerade an alle leute auf dem domplatz
hier um ein alter film 1000 leute also
das recht die verlorene tochter carola
dazugekommen wie gehts hier
hier gibt's aber dass er nichts neues
ich finde es wichtig richtig kalt hast
so viele mit am start sind was ihre
stimme erhoben haben diesen brillen
artikel 3 uns einfach das internet
versandt hat es ist wichtig dass wir den
leuten sagen zeigen was dieser artikel
ist wasser befüllt auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht der tag internetbenutzer bin aber
es ist generell einfach wichtig für eine
ganze generation ist eine ganze kultur
[Applaus]
hier sind keine mods alle zusammen
wenn ich gesagt wir lassen uns auch
nicht verarschen wir zeigen dass wir da
sind bis europa wahl am 23
dritter finden europaweit demos statt
bleibt immer friedlich und wenn menschen
draußen herum sich wundern was wir
machen klärt sie aufregt redet mit euren
eltern darüber mit ihren großeltern und
geschwister reden darüber aktiviert sie
und lasst euch nicht die freiheiten sind
keine birds erwachsenen der alten
menschen die überhaupt nicht vom
internet versteht und auch
[Applaus]
das war es jetzt hier mit der demo liebe
freunde da hinten sitzen gerade noch die
leute herum unterhalten sich es wurden
gerade auf youtube ihr leben gehalten
nämlich auch echt ganz ganz viele
zuschauer getroffen weiß auch nicht
warum meine videos schaut auf jeden fall
weil die demo echt sehr cool sie war
sehr friedlich sie war sehr laut wir
waren 1000 bis 2000 menschen dafür dass
200 leute geplant waren war das auf
jeden fall ein voller erfolg und spaß
gemacht dabei zu sein
die letzten worte zur demonstration hat
der sandra internet diesem wieder zu
hause angekommen das war es jetzt mit
der demonstration gegen artikel 13
was hat sie gesagt das war's jetzt hier
mit der demonstration gegen artikel 13
mädchen wieder zu hause angekommen was
ich einfach krass findet wie man
wirklich innerhalb von 23 tagen so
unfassbar viele menschen akquirieren
kann also 1000 bis 2000 leute die sich
einfach treffen um zusammen gegen etwas
protestieren was sie ab was ich halt
auch ihre findet dass die petition für
die ich auch damals schon werbung
gemacht habe dass mittlerweile über 4,7
millionen unterschriften hat ich habe
gehört dass heidi am öftesten
unterschriebene petition aller zeit mit
europa also es ist schon krass systeme
ist natürlich das heute wie jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben zuschauer ich hoffe
euch hat es gefallen wie ich einerseits
versucht habe das ganze als ernstes
thema zu verpackten also die ganze
demonstration braucht er anderen seite
einen typischen dummen blog kuba zu
bringen durch beispielsweise sandra ich
habe drei dass man es hier mit dem
heutigen video und ich hoffe ich konnte
ihn enthält noch einige leute davon
überzeugen die petition unterschreiben
die unten in der beschreibung steht
wirklich wählen weil das ist das einzige
was wäre wirklich machen können um die
leute die da oben sitzt und so eine
scheiße wirklich sehr kompletten artikel
dazu nachdenke habe ich ein paar andere
videos und nachrichten artikel und in
der beschreibung ebenfalls
schau dir ich gern mal an zu leben habe
ich euch auch noch eine website in der
video beschreibung verlinkt auf der ihr
alle mitglieder des europäischen
parlaments aufgelistet und besonders
seht ihr dort auch wer gegen den artikel
13 gestimmt hat und wer besonders auch
für den artikel 13 gestimmt hat neben
den mitgliedern stehen die e mail
adressen und ihr könnt den ja mal
einfach ganz freundlich nachricht
schreiben warum ihr gegen artikel 13
seit und vielleicht verstehen sie warum
der das komplette internet zerstören
würde und außerdem habe ich euch auch
noch diese website in der beschreibung
verlinkt das ist eine website auf der
ihr seht wanne vielleicht auch in eurer
nähe in den nächsten tagen in den
nächsten wochen demonstrationen gegen
artikel 3 10 stattfinden werden ich kann
mich nur sagen geht dort hin da ja
anscheinend die 4,7 millionen
unterschriften mehr der petition
allesamt ignoriert wurden ist das
wahrscheinlich mit die letzte hoffnung
die wir haben also geht raus auf die
straße
nehmt euch ein kumpel eine freundin und
ja steht auf für eure rechte ich würde
mich freuen wenn ihr dieses video mit
einem daumen hoch bewerten würde
schreibt uns eure meinungen zu der
ganzen sache und in die kommentare und
bitte schickt dieses video hier auch
vielleicht an freunde bekannte und macht
euch auf eure eltern omas opas onkel
tante auf dieses ganze thema aufmerksam
dankeschön
[Musik]